bonjour et bienvenue dans sens public
l'émission qui donne du sens à
l'actualité nous sommes le jeudi 2
novembre et nous sommes ensemble pour 1
he et3 de débat et de décryptage au 27e
jour de la guerre entre Israël et le
Hamas sommes-nous en train d'assister à
un tournant les bombardements par
l'armée israélienne du plus grand camp
de réfugiés de la banque de Gaza pour
éliminer un dirigeant du Hamas ont fait
de nombreuses victimes et susciter
l'indignation de l'ONU et de la
communauté internationale alors israël
peut-il s'entêter dans cette stratégie
mortifère au risque qui sait un jour de
perdre le précieux soutien de ses alliés
c'est une des questions à laquelle
répondront nos experts dans le premier
débat dans la seconde partie de cette
émission nous célébrerons un
anniversaire un peu méconnu un peu
oublié celui de la grande marche pour
l'égalité et contre le racisme un peu
vite baptisé à l'époque en 1983 par les
journaux Marche des beurs alors 40 ans
après cette mobilisation inédite des
immigrés de la seconde génération qu'en
reste-t-il quell leçons ont tiré et quel
combat reste d'actualité nous en débatt
patron avec mes invités à partir de
18h45 mais tout de suite place à notre
premier débat alors que tal poursuit ses
bombardements et déploie désormais ces
troupes dans la bande de Gaza que
peut-on attendre que faut-il redouter de
cette offensive terrestre retour sur ces
dernières heures avec jérô Rabier
l'armée israélienne continue sa
progression dans la bande de Gaza en
réponse à l'offensive du Hamas du 7
octobre dernier les soldats de tsal
avancent en particulier au centre de
l'enclave palestinienne dont il pour
pourit d'ici quelques heures ou jours
contrôler une bande allant de la mer à
la frontière israélienne rendant ainsi
tout de suite vers le sud impossible
mais la progression est lente et la
résistance est forte les combattants des
forces de défense israélienne continuent
de progresser dans la ville de Gaza et
mènent des combats au corps à corps avec
les terroristes du Hamas et
approfondissent les combats au cours de
la nuit les forces ont combattu de
nombreux terroristes qui ont tenté de
leur tendre une embuscade une
progression au sol qui s'accompagne
toujours de frappes enne massive mardi
et mercredi le camp de réfugiés de
Jabaliya au nord-est de l'enclave a été
frappé par au moins deux missiles
faisant des centaines de blessés et
morts les enfants palestiniens sont
anéantis où est le monde entier
sauvez-nous des enfants meurent je jure
que ce sont des enfants ceux qui disent
qu'il y a des dirigeants du Hamas ici je
jure qu'il n'y a pas de ces dirigeants
je jure devant Dieu que ce sont des
femmes et des enfants qui meurent ici
c'est de bombardements sur un camp de
réfugié palestinien ont déclenché des
critiques de la communauté
internationale l'ONU dénonçant de
possibles crimes de guerre et la France
déplorant des frappes touchant la
population
civile la France est profondément
inquiète du très lourd bilan pour les
populations civiles palestiniennes des
frabes israéliennes contre le camp de
jajbalya et exprime sa compassion à
l'égard des victimes elle rappelle que
la protection des populations civile est
une obligation du droit international
qui s'impose à tous côté humanitaire le
le poste frontière de Rafa seul point
d'accès reliant Gaza au reste du monde
par l'Égypte laisse passer au
comptegoutteelide humitaire essentiel
pour les plus de 2 millions de Gazaoui
dans le sens inverse les étrangers ou
binationaux au nombre de 7000 à Gaza
commencent à pouvoir sortir après un
premier convoi hier comprenant notamment
5 humanitaires français 400 personnes
ont ou doivent être évacué aujourd'hui
vers l'Égypte qui accueille aussi des
blessés ne pouvant plus être soignés
dans la de
gaz la situation au 27e jour de guerre
entre Israël et le Hamas on en parle ce
soir avec mes invités bonsoir Mariam pi
pirzad vous êtes rédactrice en chef à
France 24 ancienne correspondante à than
et fine connaisseuse des enjeux du
Proche Orient à vos côté bigN naabi
bonsoir vous êtes professeur de droit à
lupec consultant international au
cabinet lisias Partners et puis auteur
de relations internationales droit
théorie et pratique paru aux éditions
pédon Guillaume Ancel bonsoir ancien
officier écrivain auteur du blog ne pas
subir et puis Tam tranui qui
m'accompagnera évidemment tout au long
de cette émission comme éditorialiste
bonsoir à tous Alors je voudrais
commencer cette émission en revenant sur
ces frappes sur le camp de jajbaliya le
plus grand camp de réfugiés de la bande
de Gaza alors autant dire que c'est
c'est quasiment une ville hein 116000
réfugiés enregistrés je crois qu'il y a
26 écoles deux centres de santé donc
bombarder ce camp pour en fait éliminer
un homme Ibrahim biari qui est désigné
par l'armée israélienne comme étant l'un
des responsables de l'attaque terroriste
du 7 octobre euh bombarder un camp pour
éliminer un homme est-ce qu'on n'est pas
pour le coup dans une attaque un peu
disproportionnée Mariam pierzad une
attaque assumée par par l'armée
israélienne c'est ce qu'ils indiquent
depuis plusieurs plusieurs semaines déjà
depuis plusieurs jours que les victimes
civiles seront des victimes collatérales
mais la priorité c'est d'éliminer le
Hamas moi je pense que ces images ch il
y a eu deux bombardements de frappes et
on voit bien la puissance mercredi quand
on voit ces images c'est un cratère dans
dans dans la terre alors il y a
des une professeur d'université à Tel
Aviv qui disait mais regardez en fait ce
qui est tombé ce sont les tunnels du
hamaas c'est pour ça que ça s'effondrait
mais je pense que là on a un tournant
pour l'opinion publique pour l'émotion
publique là les images sont absolument
insoutenables on touche des enfants ce
camp-l comme vous le dites c'est le plus
grand camp de Gaza 116000 personnes
quand on frappe un camp de 116000
personnes pour tuer une personne du
Hamas qui n'est même pas un des chefs du
Hamas parce que il cherche Mohamed Daif
notamment qui est euh l'un des cerveau
présumé l'un des cerveaux présumés des
attaques terroristes du 7 du 7 octobre
en Israël qui est caché qui est caché
dans les tunnel le problème pour tsal
actuellement quelle est la solution
parce que sous sous là où vivent les
populations civil sous ce camp sont
installés des tunnels qui font parfois
60 m de profondeur on va sûrementir bien
sûr et donc eux voilà ce qui est assumé
et on a pu assister aussi à un tend au
moment de la du bombardement sur
l'hôpital on se rappelle de du
bombardement sur l'hôpital et on a très
vite su qu'en fait c'était une bavure
palestinienne d'une et c'est assumé de
la part de l'armée israélienne sur des
populations civiles à Gaza on a franchi
un cap Belling naabi avec ces
bombardements moi je dirais qu'on est
plutôt dans la succession d'événements
qui se ressembleent c'est plutôt le fait
que le processus sallonge dans le temps
qui fait que ça pèse de plus en plus sur
la conscience internationale j'ose pas
dire sur la conscience de la communauté
internationale parce qu'il n'y a pas de
bloc il n'y a pas non plus de
condamnation unanime il n'y a pas de
condamnation des alliés d'Israël
vis-à-vis de ces bombardements autrement
dit la France on y viendra mais quand
même elle condamne non vous avez montré
un un communiqué officiel il y a pas de
condamnation oui le mot condamnation n'y
est pas c'est terme préoccupation voilà
des préoccupations mais là on parle
quand même monte on on va yenir il y a
effectivement quand même des des civils
qui sont victimes finalement de
bombardement qui relève de bombardement
indiscriminés vu la proportion de mort
civiles et qui relève par définition de
ce qu'on appelle des crimes de guerre ce
ne serait pas les premiers en la matière
il y a de plus en plus de voix qui
s'expriment au sein de l'ONU et parmi la
communauté des juristes pour qualifier
ce qui se passe à Gaza de ce qu'on
appelle un génocide tout simplement
entre guillemets avec un élément
extrêmement intéressant pour pouvoir
qualifier ce qui se passe de
génocide c'est l'intention c'estàd que
pour distinguer finalement un simple
entre guillemets crime de guerre d'un
génocide c'est enfin ça réside dans le
fait de démontrer la volonté de s'en
prendre à un peuple en tant que tel pas
un peuple à un groupe du fait de son
origine ethnique raciale ou religieuse
là en
l'occurrence alors il faut rechercher
cet élément
d'intentionnalité et je dirais que il
existe dès lors que on a à notre
disposition une série de déclarations
officielles de responsables israéliens
militair ou politique qui tend à ne pas
distinguer les euh membres du Hamas des
civils de Gaza et dès lors cette
indistinction bah relève précisément
d'une forme d'indifférenciation et donc
d'une forme d'intentionnalité alors on
va évidemment y revenir on est dans le
registre de la vengeance ou dans un
objectif stratégique Guillaume Ansel
c'était qui c'est c'est Ibrahim biari
c'était vraiment une cible très
importante ouais en fait ça l'est pas ça
n'est pas une cible importante c'està
dire que c'est un sous souschef du Hamas
le le patron du Hamas il est au Qatar
hein donc quand les Israéliens disent
que
Bran pardon mais il y a pas vraiment de
différence entre les deux c'est bien ça
le problème d'Israël c'est que quand
Israël ou plutôt le gouvern netaniaah
affiche son intention de guerre les
Américains ont demandé d'éclaircir les
but de guerre son intention c'est de
détruire les capacité militaire du Hamas
mais il y a pas de capacité militaire du
Hamas pardonnez-moi il y a pas d'armée
conventionnelle c'est pas la guerre duum
Kip pour il y a pas de char il y a pas
de base là ce bombardement il visait un
souschef du Hamas qui était
immédiatement remplacé et c'est
l'illustration parfaite du piège dans
lequel le Hamas voulait emmener
Israël le Hamas s'installe au milieu de
la population palestinienne c'est
intentionnellement qu'il sont installés
là et je ne doute pas comme l'a dit
l'armée israélienne qui avait
effectivement une cellule pas une
personne mais sans doute quatre ou C de
commandementle qui était qui était
installé là tout simplement au milieu de
la population civile mais là où Israël a
une politique démonte ce gouvernement
netanahou c'est qui balance une bombe de
250 kg pour faire ça j'ai guidé des
bombardements pendant des années quand
on fait ça on sait qu'on provoque un
carnage ils sont un ratio pour une cible
militaire ils vont tuer au moins 10
civil quand vous tuez avec une bombe de
STPE compte tenu de la densité de
population qu' avait sur le site ils ont
fait au minimum je ne parle que de la
première frappe 50 morts ça veut dire
200 blessés 250 victimes civiles pour
éliminer quat membres du Hamas qui en
plus ne sont pas la tête du Hamas ça n'a
aucun sens et c'est-à-dire que Israël
est en train de se discréditer
totalement exactement comme le voulait
le Hamas pourquoi il y a un tir le
deuxème jour le mercredi parce que le
Hamas revient dans le camp et serait
inst sans doute au même endroit en
disant les Israéliens de nouveau vont
être face à ce dilemme est-ce qu' nous
laisse continuer à coordonner des
opérations alors qu'on est au milieu la
population civile où est-ce qu'ils font
la connerie de venir nous rebombarder
dessus et c'est exactement ce que fait
Israël c'està-dire qu'on est rentré dans
un jeu où la monstruosité n'a plus de
limite on savait que la guerre c'est une
vallée de sang et de larme mais là ce
qui est en train de faire Israël est
totalement disproportionné par rapport à
la légitimité qu'ils avaient de vouloir
se défendre contre le Hamas et surtout
ils font du Hamas un acteur
incontournable du peuple palestinien
alors que s'ils avaient réfléchi à une
stratégie de sortie de crise ils
essayeraient à tout prix de séparer les
deux de ne surtout pas faire souffrir la
population palestinienne du fait qu'il
veuilleent s'attaquer au Hamas on
rappelle que tout ça était évidemment
très imriqué vous disiez tout à l'heure
que il y avait plus peut-être de
distinction entre le Hamas et la
population civile or qui vient d'être
confirmé d'une certaine man Israël se
défend en disant qu'ils ont prévenu les
populations civiles de Gaza d'évacuer le
le le nord de la bande de Gaza euh
c'était totalement hypocrite pour
vous on vous informe sans vous laisser
vraiment le choix enfin d'allès compqué
de fuir ou d'esquiver le bombardement ou
ce type de bombardement oui c'est un
c'est un argument qui qui pas très
consistant pour dire la vérité par
contre à travers nos premiers échanges
on est au cœur vraiment de la
problématique premièrement la stratégie
mise en place par l'armée israélienne
traduit en réalité l'absence de solution
politique ou de perspectiv politique on
ne sait pas vers où on va et à partir du
moment où il y a pas de perspective
politique la stratégie militaire résumé
par des bombardements et une offensive
terrestre qui elle-même n'est pas n'a
pas véritablement de sens dans la mesure
on ne sait pas en quoi les objectifs
vont atteindre vont vont vont traduire
une victoire et quel type de victoire ça
pourrait signifier bien on est face à à
une impasse et deuxièmement et là ça
concerne les deux agoniste Hamas et
armée
israélienne on est dans une entreprise
de déshumanisation le Hamas ce qu'il a
commis le 7 octobre pour faire ce qu'il
a fait bah ça relève d'une d'une
entreprise mentale presque de
dshumanisation de l'autre dumanisation
l'autre n'est plus un humain donc je
suis capable de faire
l'inomable fait00 morts on le
rappelle de la même manière pour pouvoir
commettre de tels
actes côté l'armée mais israélienne il
faut être en capacité ou être avoir
atteint un degré de déshumanisation du
palestinien le problème c'est que
précisément on souligne souvent que le
Hamas ce n'est pas Israël un état de
droit démocratique moi je vois au
contraire qu'il y a un véritable
problème quant à la nature d'Israël
c'est c'est un état certes et son
existence son existence n'est pas remise
en cause mais sa nature démocratique
elle est plus que jamais discutable dans
la la mesure où tous ce a élections une
liberté d'expression ça c'est c'est une
définition j'allais dire primaire
originelle de la démocra qu'il faut
rappeler quand même il y a pas
d'élection mond de G oui mais
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle une
démocratie c'est c'est un état de droit
démocratique c'estàdire que lorsque vous
agissez même en tant que dirigeant
politique élu vous devez rendre compte
devant les électeurs mais pas seulement
vous devez rendre compte aussi
juridiquement de vos actes ce qui
caractérise aujourd'hui les soldats les
colons et les dirigeants israélien c'est
leur
impunité ce principe d'impunité il est
absolument contraire à l'état de droit
contraire absolument aujourd'hui vous
avez des images de Colon en sjordanie
qui assassine au quotidien ils ne
répondent de rien ils sont même soutenus
par les institutions la première des
institutions israéliennes qui est
l'armée ok donc ça c'est indépassable
comme réalité tout le monde le voit
c'est public et puis de l'autre vous
avez des actes
qui encore une fois ne sont pas
absolument nouveaux c'est une nouvelle
guerre à
Gaza qui s'inscrit à la suite d'un fait
sans précédent qui est l'attaque du
Hamas mais le conflit opposant le Hamas
à Israël s'inscrit dans une longue
lignée qui s'est déjà caractérisé par le
fait que les différents protagonistes se
sont enfin n'ont répondu de rien du
point de vue de leurs actes et leurs
antagonismes alimenté on en a souvent
parlé sur ce plateau vous vouliz
intervenir vous vous disiez que israël
considère la population Gazaoui comme
quasiment 2 millions de victimes
collatérales est-ce que vous direz que
le Hamas aussi d'une certaine façon en
assumant et bien de rester au cœur de la
population est-ce que cette
déshumanisation est des deux côtés et
bien vis-à-vis de cette population que
l'on voit aujourd'hui par exemple oui
clairement je va dire quelque chose qui
peut être un peu choquant mais pour moi
aujourd'hui les la population civile de
Gaza est doublement doublement a Tage
des bombardements israéliens et aage du
Hamas le Hamas appris à gagner des
élections certes mais toute tentative de
de de pouvoir
exprimer une
revendication une colère contre ce
groupe et absolument muré dans le
silence on voit cette vidéo qui tourne
beaucoup depuis ce matin d'une d'unee
d'une femme de Gaza qui hurle j'en veux
à ces gens du Hamas et on lui met la
main sur sur sur la bouche donc bien sûr
le Hamas en s'installant au cœur de la
population civile en dessous des
habitations de la de la population et
d'ailleurs il y a cette phrase
assez qui qui a qui prend tout son sens
aujourd'hui c'est un des dirigeants du
Hamas qui dit voilà en fait c'est à
l'ONU de gérer la population civile de
Gaza nous nous c'est ce n'est pas notre
rôle donc bien sûr ils sont ils sont
aage ils sont a Tage jamass rendez-nous
faut qu'on se rende compte de ce qui est
la bande de Gaza on en a parlé et parlé
mais c'est minuscule la bande de Gaza
c'est je crois la l'une des la partie du
monde qui est la plus densément peuplée
quand vous regardez ces 12 km de large
ils n'ont nulle part où aller quand ils
disent oui c'est c'est c'est ça un peu
vous parlez d'hypocrisie de l'armée
israëlienne je vous rejoins là-dessus
quand ils disent oui mais on leur a
demandé de partir du Nord on leur a
laissé plusieurs jours de pour partir du
Nord aller vers le sud ils bombardent
aussi le sud donc aujourd'hui comme le
dit l'ONU et plusieurs ONG les rares qui
qui sont encore sur place il n'y a aucun
endroit sûr à Gaza aujourd'hui alors on
va parler notamment de ce qui était visé
selon l'armée israélienne donc il y a
cet homme dont on a parlé mais il y a
aussi toutes les infrastructures le
fameux système de de tunnel je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu'en disait le
ministre israélien de la défenseav
galante
regardez les soldats décrivent ce qu'ils
rencontre partout les terroristes
sortent des puits des tunnels
souterrains sous les bâtiments sous les
hôpitaux sous les écoles il voit tout
Gaza est une base du terrorisme et du
mal
nous n'avons pas eu le choix dans cette
guerre nous devons gagner la guerre
quelqu'en soit le prix et la durée et
même si certaines nations du monde ne
l'apprécient pas nous continuerons
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons vaincu
l'organisation
Hass alors pour reprendre les mots du
ministre de la défense des terroristes
qui sortent de partout depuis de tunnel
comment israël peut-il imaginer
éradiquer ce système d'infrastructure
déjà est-ce qu'on peut faire un point
expliquer au téléspectateurs ce que ça
représente ces tunnel on parle de
centaines de kilomètres de tunnel choant
ce que vient de dire le ministre de la
Défense israélien quand il dit c'est la
base du mal Gaza et la base du mal ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que dans son
esprit il faut raser Gaza pour éradiquer
le mal ça n'a aucun sens les tunnels on
connait très bien le sujet des tunnels
les Américains s' sont essayés pendant
la guerre du Vietnam on y a tous été
confrontés moi à sarayevo il y avait des
tunnels partout quand j'y étais mais
mais en fait on ne sait pas détruire un
tunnel sans détruire ce qu'il y a
au-dessus donc on détruire les tunnels
il y en a partout à Gaza donc on détruit
tout Gaza pour qu'il y ait plus tunnel
de toute façon un tunnel dès que le le
terrain s'est rétabli on le recreuse
c'est pas en détruisant un tunnel que
vous détruisez le Hamas c'est exactement
comme quand le Hamas dit on a pardon
quand l'armée israélienne dit on a
détruit un quartier général du Hamas
c'est un appartement dans un immeuble
dans lequel on a déposé des postes radio
et trois postes informatiques il
déménage dans l'immeuble d' à côté pour
détruire des termites vous détruisez pas
la maison ça n'a aucun sens de dire
qu'on détr éuit le lieu où se rassemble
le Hamas en fait on s'est pas attaqué au
Hamas on détruit la surface en laissant
penser à la population civile que si
jamais ils soutenaent le Hamas en
réalité c'est eux qui seraiit puni mais
c'est tnel il joue un rôle essentiel à
la fois pour
alimenter la bande de Gaza en armes on a
vu aussi parfois en provision en
nourriture est-ce que déjà ils sont
répertoriés ils sont catographiés est-ce
qu'on sait où sont précisément c'est
uneunnel c'est une question naïve mais
mais déjà la question que que moi je me
pose depuis 3 semaines déjà devant euh
on a tous été stupéfait quand même de
l'inaction des renseignements israéliens
qui n'ont pas vu venir cette attaque du
Hamas qui sont censés être les meilleurs
renseignements au monde comment ils
n'ont pas pu voir cette prolifération de
tunnels ça va jusqu'à 60 m de profondeur
avec des tunnels qui arrivent notamment
dans la mer où il y a une opération
amphibie qui a qui a failli être menée
également par par par des par des gens
de Hamas euh mais là il mise notamment
sur le le foule euh pourquoi israël
refuse de livrer du fioule parce que à
60 m de profondeur ils ont besoin de
générateur pour s'oxygéner de système de
ventilation de ventilation donc ils ont
visiblement le Hamas a visiblement
provisionner assez de carburant et de
foule pour faire fonctionner ces C ces
appareils pour qu'il y ait de l'air sous
les tunnels mais à un moment donné ça
n'a pas une ça c'est une capacité
limitée c'estàd qu'ils ont quelques
semaines à venir à un moment donné ils
vont devoir sortir du tunnel donc qu la
ventilation sera plus assurée les
tunnels seront inutilisable voilà mais
le problème de ce fu de ce carburant
qu'raë refuse de laisser passer dans la
bande de Gaza c'est qu'ils alimentent
aussi les hôpitaux et c'est là en fait à
chaque fois cette cette opération
absolument binaire qui est qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui il y a
quelques instants l'OMS déclaré que 14
hôpitaux sur 36 à Hamas ne peuvent plus
fonctionner parce que les appareils ne
fonctionnent plus donc ça veut dire quoi
les bébés dans les couveuses ne pourront
plus être oxygéné les personnes qui sont
reliées à des appareils donc se pose
cette problématique et qui qui est
absolument insoluble en fait pour pour
pour tout le monde alors le oui vous
voulez intervenir je crois qu' on met
pas assez l'accent aujourd'hui sur
l'aspect siège de la bande de Gaza parce
que là on parle essentiellement des
combats mais aujourd'hui on arrive à un
point où en fait il va y avoir plus de
morts du fait du siège de la bande de
Gaza que des combats de l'armée
israélienne on va y venz aux conditions
aux conditions humanitaires mais je je
voulais finir vraiment ce ce chapitre
sur sur
Jabalya parce que le bombardement enfin
les bombardement puisquil en a eu deux à
deux reprises indigné beaucoup de
chancellerie le secrétaire général des
Nations Unies Antonio guterz s'est dit
atterrer pour le Haut Commissariat aux
Droits de l'Homme de l'ONU ces
bombardements pourra même constituer des
crimes de guerre compte tenu du nombre
élevé de victimes civiles et de
l'ampleur des destructions donc ça peut
engager là pour le coup des des des
poursuites par la Cour pénale
internationale notamment alors ce qui
est intéressant effectivement moi j'ai
souvent à l'esprit quand même la
séquence internationale précédente on
était tous focalisés sur la guerre en
Ukraine et là on est quand même marqué
par le contraste des réactions ant des
chanelleries mais aussi la Cour pénale
internationale qui était ex qui a été
exemplaire dans le la guerre en Ukraine
en ce sens où elle a été réactive par
rapport au crimes de guerre qui ont été
perpétrés par les soldats russes en en
lançant une enquête assez rapidement en
étant sur le terrain avec des
délégations fortes en mobilisant aussi
les États pour l'aider à enquêter et à à
qualifier les les actes et en lançant il
faut le rappeler un mandat international
contre Vladimir Poutine l'acte
symbolique et d'une puissance sans
précédent pour le coup là c'est silence
radioou presque on rappelle juste
puisque comparaison n'est pas raison et
qu'on peut rappeler les deux conflit
mais que on a une agression de la Russie
en Ukraine dans un cas et puis on a une
riposte même si on peut la juger
disprortionné de d'Israël à Gaza après
une attaque qui a fait tu j'aurais parlé
du Maroc je trouve que l'attitude du
Maroc est très intéressante parce que
c'est un des pays qui a le plus soutenu
l'Ukraine c'est un pays qui qui a
toujours une position très équilibrée
vis-à-vis d'Israël et Don la guerre en
Ukraine c'est un des pays qui tout de
suite a dit on doit empêcher la Russie
de pouvoir envahir l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
je suis très proche de certains
officiers marocains les Marocains sont
hulcérés parce qu'ils disent est-ce
qu'on aurait toléré que les Ukrainiens
bombardent la population civile russe au
prétexte que ils ont subi des
bombardements des crimes des exactions
terribles on se souvient de ce que les
Russes on se souvient ils en font encore
oui en Ukraine on nurait jamais accepté
ça et donc les Marocains me disent nous
on peut peut pas continuer à soutenir un
bloc d'alliés il y a 50 pays alliés qui
soutenaient l'Ukraine si à l'intérieur
de ce bloc on considère qu'il y a deux
poids de mesure si on considère que
quand ce sont les Israéliens qui
réagissent parce que les Marocains ne ne
contestent pas du tout le droit légitime
c'est comme ça qu'il le décrivent du
fait que Israël se défende mais se
défendre ça ne peut pas être d'aller
provoquer des carnages dans la
population civile à Gaza et en fait
eufense légitime pardon ça serait quoi
une défense légitime pour moi ce serait
qui pour chasse le Hamas en prenant leur
temps et surtout en le séparant de la
bande de Gaza c'està-dire c'est des
opérations ciblées façon Septembre noir
enfin le la la la chasse des des des des
auteurs de septembre je pensais plutôt
que les Israéliens qui en général sont
connus pour la pertinence de leur
stratégie militaire c'est vraiment pas
le cas aujourd'hui au lieu d'aller
exactement là où le Hamas les attendait
c'est-à-dire cette attaque terrestre
sans but réel militaire ça aurait été de
faire tout le contraire d'ouvrir la
bande de Gaza pour que les Palestiniens
se désolidarisent du Hamas et que les
membres du qui ont commis cette attaque
bestiale contre Israël le 7 octobre ne
puisse plus avoir aucune alternative que
de se retrouver seul dans la bande de
Gaza à un moment un autre et un moment
où un commando israélien serait all
chercher il n'urit jamais où les
Palestiniens les Palestiniens seraient
rester mais par contre ils auraient eu
la possibilité de pouvoir rentrer sur le
sol israélien vous vous imaginez ce que
c'est que de vivre à l'ombre d'une
clôure électrifié et gardé en permanence
c'est un camp de prisonniers à ciel
ouvert en ouvrant ce camp de prisonniers
je pense que beaucoup de Palestiniens se
seraient désolidarisés du Hamas oui mais
le Hamas comment comment reconnaître
quelqu'un du Hamas dans la population
civile il retirent leur vestes c'est un
CIV ce sont des civils comme n'importe
qui m de
protection c'est une vraie difficulté et
en même temps vous
écoutant on se on se dit ah la normalité
quand même pour le pour le pour Gaza
c'est le blocus le retour à la normale
une fois le conflit terminé ça sera le
retour à une clôture et une prison à
ciel ouvert c'est ça la normalité pour
revenir quand même à ce que vous disiez
votre question sur finalement la
réaction des états ce qui est très
intéressant outre maintenant le fait que
c'est acté et c'est quand même un
épisode important dans la vie
international le discours à géométrie
variable le double standard est devenu
une faille dans la préttion occidentale
qui qui est quand même le fondement de
l'ordre international tel qu'il est né
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale a posé
un droit international universel ça
c'est fini c'est fini à cause de la
guerre en Ukraine et maintenant à
cause c'est fini et on na pas termin
juste un élément oui non mais vous allez
répondre à cette question je vais
rappeler quand même les les les les les
positions des uns et des autres parce
que le qued d'ora se dit profondément
inquiet du très lourd bilan pour les
populations civiles palestiniennes des
frappes israéliennes contre le camp de
de jab Jabalia il exprime sa compassion
à l'égard des victimes est-ce que vous
notez un changement de ton oui parce que
alors c'est l'autre aspect oui vous avez
raison de souligner un changement de ton
de Washington à Paris y compris Berlin
mais ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que ce changement de ton des état et
donc de leur diplomatie de leur
chancellerie procède essentiellement de
l'influence ou de la pression des
opinions publiques et c'est le fait
majeur je pense aussi dans la mesure où
on a pu assister notamment lors du
dernier weekend à des mobilisations
populaires massive pas seulement dans le
monde arabe parce qu'on essae de rendre
de transformer ce conflit à une lecture
le réduire à une lecture soit religieuse
soit ethnique alors que en réalité ce
qui est parfois le cas oui mais le
réduire ça c'est un aspect mais si vous
avez des mobilisations à Los Angeles
dans les pays nordiques ou en Amérique
du Sud vous savez vous avez des pays en
Amérique du Sud qui soit ont rompu leurs
relations diplomatique avec Israël soit
leurs ambassadeurs la chie la Colombie
ou lecture je termine juste vous voyez
bien que la grille de lecture religieuse
ou ethnique n'est pas la bonne c'est
c'est autre chose qui se joue et je
disais donc que si les pays occidentaux
évoluent aussi c'est parce que leur
opinion publique sont sensibles à ce
qu'elle voit eu égard à leur valeur
alors Anthony blinken le secrétaire
d'État américain est attendu demain àtel
avis il sera aussi ce weekend en
Jordanie il vient de déclarer que les
États-Unis étaient déterminés à éviter
toute escalade du conflit est-ce que là
c'est un changement de ton est-ce que
quelque chose peut changer entre Israël
et les États-Unis mari pi non la seule
chose qu' peut penser c'est l'échéance
électorale dans un an les é États-Unis
vote pour l'élection présidentielle
Donald Trump était en bonne position
dans les sondages et là on voit de plus
en plus aux États-Unis qui a quand même
notamment avec l'IPAC qui est un peu le
grand
lobby pour approcher Israël et les
États-Unis l'IPAC est de plus en plus
critiqué et on voit de nombreuses
critiques qui émanent aussi au sein de
la société américaine contre ce soutien
inconditionnel des États-Unis à Israël
mais le fait qu'il retourne demain quand
même ça veut dire quoi il est
retourneain parce que des négociations
sont en cours il y a plein de
négociations on a appris aujourd'hui par
exemple que la Thaïlande s'est rendu à
Theran pour négocier avec des des
personnes VI se sont rendu à Theran et
des représentants de la
Thaïlande se sont rendus également
interant ils s'y sont rencontrés pour
négocier la libération de 22 otages
thaïlandais mais pour revenir un mot sur
l'ONU il y a une image qui est passé un
peu inaperçue la semaine dernière c'est
le chef de la diplomatie iranienne Hir
Hosin abdolayon qui a été reçu à l'ONU
avec Antonio gouterz qui lui sert la
main tout sourire donc ça dit bien aussi
de ce deux poids de mesure don dont on
parle de l'ONU moi je pense pas que euh
il y a pas de changement de ton le
problème c'est que là l'ONU commence le
seul changement de ton que j'ai pu voir
ces derniers jours c'est l'ONU et les
experts indépendants qui parlent de
potentiel crime de guerre qui disent
attention les alliés d'Israël ont une
responsabilité et là quand si les
États-Unis sont donc se sont sont en
train de se faire un peu lâcher par la
Jordanie he
l'ambassadeur l'ambassadeur israélien a
été rappelé mais il y a la Jordanie avec
qui les États-Unis ont une bonne
relation Mohammed ben Salman a dépêché
son frère aux aux États-Unis pour
rencontrer Anthony blinken pour essayer
de maintenir un canal de de de
communication mais si les États-Unis voi
qui sont en train de perdre beaucoup de
plumes dans cette région où déjà la
Chine les a remplacé parce que les
dernières grandes victoires
diplomatiques sont été obtenu par la
Chine et pas par les États-Unis à un
moment donné peut-être que les
États-Unis vont revoir un peu le leur
leur positionnement par rapport à cette
guerre oui juste juste puisqu'on parlait
de l'ONU après juste après je vous
redonne la parole Guillaume Ancel euh on
sait que c'est bloqué au Conseil de
sécurité on sait que l'assemblée
générale de des Nations Unies a adopté
une résolution la semaine dernière et on
joue beaucoup avec les symboles dans un
coramp comme dans l'autre t oui avec
notamment lundi à l'ONU l'ambassadeur
israélien Gilad derdan qui s'est
présenté devant le Conseil de sécurité a
voulu avoir un geste marquant symbolique
pour dénoncer l'immobilisme et le
silence du Conseil écoutez et
regardez à partir de ce jour à chaque
fois que vous me regarderez vous vous
rappellerez ce que cela signifie de
rester silencieux face au
mal comme mes grandspents et les
grandsparents de millions de Juifs à
partir d'aujourd'hui mon équipe et moi
porteront des étoiles
jaunes n marcherons avec une étoile
jaune comme symbole de fierté pour
rappeler que nous avons juré de nous
battre pour nous défendre plus jamais
c'est
maintenant choqué attirer l'attention he
tel est l'objectif de l'ambassadeur qui
est arrivé à ses fins son geste a été
commenté jusqu'en Israël où Danny Dayan
le président de Yad Vashem le mémoral le
mémorial israélien de la Choa à
Jérusalem a dénoncé je cite un acte qui
déshonore les victimeses de l'Holocauste
ainsi que l'État d'Israël en expliquant
que l'étoile jaune symbolise
l'impuissance du peuple juif et sa
dépendance envers les autres nous avons
désormais un état indépendant et une
armée forte nous sommes maîtres de notre
propre destin et il a tout dit oui
arboré l'étoile jaune sur l'échelle du
buz de communication 20/ 20 niveau
pertinence délicatesse zéro pointé et
plus globalement sur ce conflit et bien
il y a eu de nombreuses analogies qui
ont été faites en référence à la seconde
garere mondiale côté Choa côté nazisme
et toujours ça a été à côté de la plaque
de l'ancien coureur mayeddine makesi qui
a dit Adolf Hitler était un enfant de
cœur à côté de netanahou à Guillaume
murce qui a parlé du Premier ministre
israélien comme une sorte de nazi sans
prépus je propose qu'on laisse de côté
l'entreprise d'extermination du trisème
Reich pour faire des bons mots ou bien
attirer l'attention à forcerie dans la
situation internationale actuelle où on
finit par accuser donc de nazisme le
principal dirigeant d'un État juif qui a
vécu le 7 octobre son pire massacre
depuis 80 ans ou qui pour un con
évidemment oui ça m'a rappelé d'ailleurs
ce moment où Simon veille défendant
l'IVG a vu ses opposants stigmatiser
l'avortement faisant référence à à la
solution finale vous l'avez dit
attention comparaison n'est pas raison
on va faire ATT attention au comparaison
mais à l'époque l'ancienne ministre
centriste a accordé le bénéfice du doute
à ses détracteurs et au fait qu'il ne
connaissait pas son histoire personnelle
et dans ces mémoires elle revient tout
de même sur ses épisodes explique que
l'une des choses qu'elle redoute avec le
plus de vigueur dans tout cela c'est le
relativisme s'agissant de
l'extermination des Juifs or nespace qui
nous guettete aujourd'hui en convoquant
cet épisode de l'histoire n'importe
comment je rappelle que l'étoile jaune a
aussi été arboré récemment dans des
marches contre l'islamophobie ou dans
des manifestations contre le Pass
sanitaire
la mémoire de la Choa elle a besoin
d'être perpétuellement entretenue d'être
expliquée d'être enseigné pas d'être
reprise à des fins de communication les
horaires de les horreurs de la guerre
actuelle au Proche Orient on les a vu
elles se suffisent aujourd'hui à
elle-même elle convoque à elle seul
suffisamment d'image du passé sans qu'on
ait besoin d'en rajouter merci Tam pour
ce coup de gueule Guillaume Ancel est-ce
que la situation le ton est en train de
changer sur sur la scène internationale
vis-à-vis d'Israël ou pour vous pas du
tout non pour moi le le ton change il y
a eu une espèce de d'unanimité au départ
sur l'attaque du Hamas qui a vraiment
choqué le monde entier y compris dans
les opinions publiques arabes au départ
quand on a su dans les premières 24
heures pas tout de suite dans les
premières 24 heures quand on a compris
la bestialité avec laquelle le Hamas
avait conduit ses attaques mais là les
opinions publiques se renversent y
compris dans des pays qui ne sont
absolument pas pro Hamas ou pro
palestinien parce que tout le monde est
choqué par en fait l'absence de
stratégie pertinente j'allais dire pas
de l'armée israélienne parce que c'est
le gouvernement néthaniaou qui décide de
la stratégie or tout à l'heure je pense
qu'on a été inexact quand on a dit que
l'armée ou Israël avait été incapable de
déceler cette menace moi j'ai des
sources sûres dans l'armée israélienne
qui m'ont confirmé que les alertes ont
été remontées au gouvernement pas
plusieurs jours avant plusieurs semaines
et plusieurs mois et que c'est le
gouvernement netaniaou qui les a écarté
ce qu'on arrive pas à savoir si c'est
c'est parce que c'était noyé dans un
flot d'alerte ou si comme le disent mes
camarades israéliens le gouvernement
netanahou a dit le seul point important
c'est la S Jordanie il y a il se passera
rien à Gaza je vous interdis de dévier
des moyens sur Gaza parce qu'on doit se
concentrer sur la S jourdanie six
jourdanie dont on oublie de rappeler que
les colons avec le l'assistance de
l'armée donc c'est bien une décision de
gouvernement c'est pas l'armée qui
décide ça terrorise les habitants enensi
Jordanie les habitants palestiniens pour
occuper leur terre donc il y a quand
même dans le comportement de ce
gouvernement israélien et dans leur
absence de stratégie militaire et dans
leur indessence vis-à-vis de ce qui se
passe en S Jordanie ça questionne le
monde entier et ce qui est triste c'est
qu'au fond israël va se retrouver sur le
ban des accusés alors que c'est elle qui
a été provoquée par le Hamas mais au
fond c'est là où le Hamas voulait
l'emmener enfin provoquer agressé on le
rappelle dans des circonstances
particulièrement terribles une de
d'autrre nouvell de ces deux derniers
jours c'est que des évacuations ont
commencé par le point de Rafa vous savez
au sud de la bande de Gaza vers l'Égypte
on va en parler avec Audry vuetaz qui va
me rejoindre puisque Audry donc des des
évacuations ont commencé des
ressortissant étrangers ou Palestiniens
détenteur de la double nationalité sont
désormais autorisés à quitter la bande
de Gaza oui regardez ça se passe au
point de passage de Rafa on est à la
frontière avec l'Égypte et sur les
véhicules on voit des drapeaux pour
signaler la nationalité des
ressortissants on va le voir dans
quelques minutes un drapeau italien il y
a aussi des chazubles Autrichiens en
tout ce sont des ressortissant de 60
nationalités qui se sont retrouvé
bloqués dans la bande de Gaza depuis le
début du conflit et qui commen donc à
passer la frontière pour sortir du pays
avec l'aide de l'Égypte depuis hier donc
depuis que la frontière s'est
entrouverte c'est eu deux vagues
d'évacuation qui ont eu lieu ça concerne
545 étrangers ou binationaux et 90
blessés Palestiniens la moitié ce sont
des enfants qui nécessite des
interventions chirurgicales qu'ils ne
peuvent pas subir dans la bande de Gaza
une ouverture exceptionnelle qui devrait
permettre à terme d'évacuer 7000
citoyens étrangers des ressortissants
qui témoignent du pire une fois la
frontière passée écoutez cette citoyenne
américaine elle fait partie des 74
citoyens américains qui ont pu quitter
la bande de Gaza d'après Joe
Biden nous avons vu des gens qui ont
perdu leurs parents des gens brûlé des
corps coupés en morceaux nous avons vu
des choses que nous n'avions jamais vu
auparavant et alors qu'en est-il pour
les ressortissants français alors de ce
qu'on sait cinq ont pu passer la
frontière hier il s'agit d'humanitaire
de première urgence et de Médecins sans
frontières d'après le clé d'orsé avant
cette évacuation il avait environ 170
personnes à protéger 50 français leurs
familles et des agents de l'Institut
français qui a donc qui attendent donc
de passer la frontière pour l'instant
pas de date précise mais ça devrait se
passer dans les prochaines heures les
prochains jours et puis on a appris hier
la mort de deux enfants de nationalité
française qui ont été tués dans le nord
de la bande de Gaza leur mère blessée
est un soutien du Hamas elle est visée
depuis 7 ans par un mandat d'arrêt
international pour association de
malfiteur en vue d'acte de terrorisme
elle a d'ailleurs été condamnée par
contumas à 6 ans d'emprisonnement pour
avoir distribué de l'argent à des
membres du Hamas Mathieu merci beaucoup
Audrey alors on voit des évacuations
humanitaires des évacuations de B
nationaux est-ce qu'on peut imaginer des
évacuations plus massives de
Palestiniens vers l'Égypte Mariam pirzad
al effectivement c'est au comptegoutte
là l'Égypte parlait effectivement de 7
1000 ressortissants mais avec des
passeports étrangers qui pourrai sortir
je crois qu'il y a plusieurs
humanitaires de Médecins sans frontières
qui ont qui ont pu quitter on parle d'un
blocus israélien mais en réalité c'est
un blocus égypto israélien l'Égypte il
faut le rappeler bloque aussi ce passage
de Rafa bah alors officiellement le
président alsissi dit qu'il ne il faut
éviter absolument une nouvelle nagba
nagba c'est la catastrophe en Arab
doncode 1948 donc lorsque des
palestinens ont été chassés de leur
terre en 1948 euh il ne faut absolument
pas qu'ils quittent la bande de Gaza
parce que sinon ils ne retrouveront pas
leur leur habitation officieusement
aucun pays arabe de la région ne veut
prendre la responsabilité de créer des
des des camps de réfugiés à ciel ouvert
comme on peut voir actuellement en
Jordanie ou une 20 % plus de 20 % de la
population en Jordanie est palestinienne
ou encore au Liban rendons-nous compte
au Liban 42 % de la population libanaise
ce sont des réfugiés réfugiés syriens
réfugiés jordaniens et ça crée des
tensions dans ces pays-là donc ces pays
alentour ne veulent pas prendre cette
cette
responsabilité d'accueillir
effectivement ces Palestiniens donc là
qu'est-ce qui se passe on l'a dit et
redit la population est absolument
bloquée entre ces quatre murs euh entre
la mer la la la fortification
électrifiée et si aujourd'hui vous
n'avez pas ce précieux sésame et moi je
suis désolée mais moi ça me choque si on
on a on peut sortir uniquement si on a
un passeport étranger mais les civils
qui n'ont pas de passeport restent
complètement livrés à eux-mêm et je
trouve qu'il y a côté un petit
peu enfin voilà je voyis choquant il y a
pas il y a pas d'autres mots c'est ce
sont des milliers des milliers de
personnes qui sont dans le dénuement le
le plus total et des images qui qui qui
qui nous bouleversent chaque jour
surtout surtout d'enfants en fait et je
je finirit sur cette phrase de quelqu'un
d'un membre de l'omu qui dit il n'y a
pas de vainqueur quand on tue quand des
enfants sont victimes et je pense qu'
elle prend tout son sens aujourd'hui
cette phrase et l'ONU vient d'annoncer
que quatre écoles abritant des réfugiés
viennent d'être toucher à l'instant
est-ce que c'est ces frappes et ces
interventions terrestres comme on le
voit c'est aussi le signe peut-être que
Israël d'une certaine façon a fait une
croix sur la question de la libération
des des otages Guillaume Hensel ah
clairement ils ont fait un choix lourd
parce que quand Benjamin netanahou
essaie de déclarer que il a déclenché
cette offensive terrestre pour récupérer
les terroristes les les pardon les
otages bien sûr des mains des
terroristes c'est qu'en réalité il a dû
faire un choix entre les deux ça n'est
pas compatible c'est soit on fait des
opérations de libération d'otagep à sont
des opérations très spéciales dans
lequel il faut agir avec une relative
finesse alors que là quand on fait une
invasion terrestre on l'a vu sur vos
images c'est un
affrontement extrêmement violent
destructeurs avec des frappes aériennes
régulières et que par conséquent les
otages serviront de boucliers humains
comme l'ont déjà expliqué le Hamas et
les brigades islamique et il commence à
annoncer qu'une partie des otages ont
été tués bien sûr par les bombardements
israéliens même si ça n'est pas vrai
mais ils mettent Israël face encore une
fois à un dilemme et je je comment dire
je ne peux pas c'est c'est c'est leur
décision de de de privilégier l'une ou
l'autre solution ce qui est clair c'est
qu'en déclenchant l'invasion terrestre
il renonce à récupérer la majorité des
otages et 382 soldats israéliens morts
depuis le 7 octobre aussi alors sur les
chiffres oui c'est toujours compliqué
parce qu'on a les chiffres israéliens on
a les chiffres je rappelle que selon le
Hamas 195 personnes aurent été tu dans
les frappes je parle dans les frappes du
du camp de de de Jabalia et près de 9000
personnes au total mais on rappelle que
ce sont des chiffres difficilement
vérifiable dans la bande de Gaza bignab
vouliez intervenir oui juste sur cette
question aussi des otages elle aussi
elle oppose un miroir elle offre un
miroir sur la nature du régime israélien
la position
d'intransigence elle va pas de soi vous
avez d'autres régimes démocratiques qui
auraient qui auraient opposé ou
développé une autre stratégie eu égard à
cette donnée qui est délicate en soit
comment
faire pour développer à la fois une
offensive terrestre tout en prenant en
considération ses vies humaines c'est
pas c'est pas une équation facile mais
il n'empêche faut entendre quand même le
discours qui est opposé par le
gouvernement actuel qui est très
intransigent qui met cette question au
second plan et qui n'arrive pas à nouer
un dialogue constructif avec les
familles des otages mais aussi avec la
société civile israélienne dans la
mesure où cette question est de plus en
plus sensible c'est pas du tout c'est
pas du tout habituel de la part d'Israël
qui jusque- là avait au contraire
échangé on se rappelle bien sûr
deahit
n c'est la nature du régime tel qui
connaît une dérive parce que là encore
malheureusement c'est c'est le jeu des
médias mais le conflit non seulement
n'est pas né le 7 octobre mais le régime
israélien non plus et en ce sens il
connaît une dérive qui s'inscrit dans un
temps long on parle de régime illibéral
vous dites oui c'est une démocratie oui
mais pas n'importe quelle démocratie
difficile d'être en comparaison aussi à
ce qui se passe côté palestinien on n
pas franchement dans démocratie et dans
la région contr bien sûr mais à
l'échelle internationale c'est quand
même un régime démocratique qui arrive à
allier un État colonial et ça c'est
carrément presque une exception sur la
scène internationale on voit bien que
l'équation est impossible et à un moment
donné une fois cette séquence
conflictuelle guerrière terminé on va
revenir à l'équation politique à
laquelle les Israéliens en tant que tels
sont confrontés en en tant que citoyen
en tant que démocrate que faire de la
politique coloniale est-ce qu'elle va
être remise en cause ou pas et ça de mon
point de vue c'est la grande question
politique qui se pose et c'est là-dessus
que nous allons conclure ce débat désolé
mais il faut un temps pour tout et il
est 18h45 on doit passer la seconde
partie de notre émission merci beaucoup
à tous les trois d'y avoir participé